[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous rendez vous il est pourtant pardon
non quel numéro demandé à écouter
monsieur craig devant le coût de
l'erreur a décompté pas vous ne vous en
sortirez qu'avec une réponse est oui ou
non
alors oui j j si je n'ai pas le mensonge
non mais dites donc il vous permet à
celle des cantons
chirac est ou serait ce déshonneur c'est
une tenue dont s'accommode beaucoup de
femmes respectables vous savez oui j'en
connais même qui en sont fiers et pas
forcément les idiots c'est à dire
sur la web série pu si un homme ne sais
pas ce que je voulais dire
pourriez vous me rappeler votre nom je
suis de jouer six communes et écoutez
franchement franchement je n'en demande
pas plus franchement oui ou non et oui
ou non quoi ni comment qui se déshabille
et vous de cette manière je n'en ai ont
continué en attendant récupérons notre
profit tout ce qui reste de me paradis
sur cette terre majeur des galapagos et
la floride et kilimandjaro chiama ou
tantôt l'ifri buvant toutes les sources
nous on y vend des espaces libres sans
scrupules sans convenance s'attirant la
terre de notre liberté
le mot
la ligne doit être encombré tout le
monde le tour du monde
48km liberté pour la bonne réponse oui
ou non je ne devrais pas moi mais je ne
pouvais plus attendre
à part ça fait long j'ai plus de temps
faire surtout le ton qui va s'asseoir
loup ce précieux cadeau tant qu'on en
sacrifier aux autres j'ignore pour qu'il
vous me prenez ma cg c'est merveilleux
qui vaut la peine d'être vécue difficile
je ne voudrais vous poser aucun stress
néanmoins je vous signale à titre
d'information que vous faites idées pour
rien je ne vous connais pas vous ne
m'avez jamais vu et vous me chiffre met
les nerfs
alors je ne vous téléphonerait plus
excellentes même le disiez vous plutôt
et merci pour vous décider dès lundi
16h30 à l'aéroport salon d'été deuxième
étage je vous y attendrez et vous
soucier de rien j'aurai votre billet en
poche via l'avion pour acapulco
techonomy c'est un requin pour acapulco
mais vous êtes choix n'allait tout de
même pas ici à les enlever vos gants de
caoutchouc
allô allô à kaboul au prix du kilomètre
puis mais il est toujours le contrat a
été signé ce matin cinq cent mille
balles de spots télé ciné radio toute
force et niété miles dentifrice
amaigrissant perdez du poids en vous
brossant les dents voilà on va t'on du
tout cela ne concerne en rien l'élite
intellectuelle déjà soumise comme chacun
sait au double régime amaigrissant de
l'ironie et du scepticisme me croirez
pas je te le dis ma jolie je suis un de
ces publicitaires maso qui ont
l'honnêteté de croire à l'efficacité de
l'ampli et à l'efficacité du produit
regardez le monter à l'assaut seule la
vraie barbarie c'est pourtant clair
jérôme ne croit aux produits n'est pas
d'avoir vu ces spots à la tv reprendrait
vous de l'andouillette l'efficacité d'un
produit ne peut être trouvée que par le
jeanne à ce que je t'ai dit appeler
clapiers jacou d'un autre rendez vous du
lundi y est
et toi quels autres bestioles crois tu
donc piégé dans ton jardin d'enfants
qu'attendez-vous du redoux y est tu peux
me dire toile et fait corps à plus tard
sur ses consommateurs en herbe le
produit que tu leur balance à longueur
de journée - sedan balance un produit
pédagogue culturel ou je ne sais quoi
apprendre et vous irlande où hier à face
à ces monstres
il est monstrueux donc honorer vous de
leur douillet se comparer ma mission
éducative apostolique et romaine ignoble
soutiens moi de faire du rendez-vous du
land où il faisait que mettre en balance
le principe d'exploitation des mass
médias à l'aube où le prof de maths ne
sortez pas vos grandes que de principe
d'archimède vous allez prendre fois vie
et moi ça me fiancer des factures oublié
ouais mais ça ne modifie en rien à sa
pointure de l'andouillette à petit 42 ce
qui à première vue ne me semble pas
besoin de reprendre et vos de nos
billets tu te sens bien fait ce temps
finalement ma main quoi cette amère mais
souhaite une réponse à cette question
elle reposait sur trois terrains raison
mon chéri ce genre de questions et moi
un privilège
je compte bien en faire un conte droite
merci ça manque
je ne vous demande pas si vous
reprendrez de l'andouillette elle était
fabuleuse dans leur sillage à beaux
jours de plus dans ma vie prenez-en de
la graine le fiancé un truc comme ça sur
le front après quinze ans de mariage
croyez-moi ça s'mérite rapide avoir sur
le flanc d'un kazan questions
troublantes un prof à trois plages et
réfléchir dès maintenant à propos
figurez vous que ce matin j'ai reçu un
coup de téléphone autant que moi je n'ai
pas la générosité infuse de ma soeur
n'est ce pas là monsieur chérif ce matin
par exemple alors que les méchants ça
pourra trouver une deuxième comme date
c'est mehdi avant l'heure à propos de
midi figure toi que ça m'a fait
remarquer j'ai toujours pensé que le
mariage et cela coûte téléphone quand je
dis penser je veux dire en raisonnant
par hypothèse de parapluies quel que
soit alors là mon vieux je vois mal
partie du comté sûr l'algèbre pour
résoudre les problèmes dus aux propos d
alger pour figure toi que ce matin j'ai
reçu un mariage c'est une affaire de
subtilité psychologique c'est la proche
permanente de ce délicat mouvement
d'horlogerie qui la femme est d'abord la
reconnaissance de ses droits
fondamentaux dont le premier de tous et
le droit à la parole figure toi que ce
matin j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone qui
implique automatiquement son droit à
l'existence il veut tellement reçu un
coup de téléphone a reçu quoi un coup de
téléphone
et alors tu moucharde d'amer trois
matches banques
mais pas du tout je dis ça parce que je
vois bien que ça n'intéresse personne -
sept personnes sur le toit pour d
apprendre qu est ce qui donne en match
ce trimestre la fois comment dire on
cherchait pas papa demande ça comme ça
la semaine dernière il a eu un 18 ans
dissertation oui mais nous parlons des
matchs chérie tu parles des matchs et ri
puis je me permettre de te faire
remarquer ce n'est pas son prof de
lettres que nous avons atteint les
hasards de l'architecturé si sa pensée
je te prie pas facile sur l'iss et les
fenêtres qui donnent sur trop jardin
d'enfants
au lieu d'être celle de la classe de mme
huff avait été celle de la classe de
littérature obama qui dans dacquois se
tout de même en regardant par la fenêtre
qui t'a connu monsieur bouyer non ici tu
peux m'appeler thomas l'autre il
s'appelle georges qui [ __ ] mon prof de
lettres georges transit célibataire 30
ans blond 1 mètre 80 barak et comme est
pliée du quinze de france si tu veux je
te présenterait et qu'il a dit dj ben
quoi l'université doit donner sa chance
à tout le monde c'est pas parce qu'on
bon revenons-en aux maths alors c'est un
corps ne voudrais pas avoir l'air de me
venger dire qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
résoudre un problème serait exagéré
j'espère que tu as presque il ya ceux
qui la tendance à préférer à la solution
juste la solution qui lui plaît dans mon
dieu que c'est joli ça tu ne trouves pas
ça joli toi collomb a préféré la
solution qui plaît à choisir à sa mesure
à sa convenance une solution aux
commandes personnalisées interdite au
public
or de toute pollution nous toi tu
trouves pas ça joli
je me permets de te faire remarquer que
tu es en train de conforter ton fils
dans sa nullité mathématiques d'unité
c'est vite dit au camp va prof
le pauvre il a la bouche pleine toile et
pour moi pourquoi les solutions qui
plaisent ne serait-elle pas les seuls
visés mais parce que il y aurait une
part d erreur juste mais enfin à tous se
trouve acapulco
pardon
prendrez-vous du fromage c'est un porc
du mexique
qu'est ce que tu racontes jeudi à
acapulco acapulco voilà des mots en leur
n'importe quoi monsieur rêve à te
préparer se rétablir en prose d'avenir
en bronze
tiens comme disent mes copains
maintenant que tu as une poupe amat à la
maison tu as plus qu'à faire le plein
l'euro ce qui n'empêche pas capoolco et
rapports du mexique
comment peut-on détester les maths à ce
point on détecte et vous entendez un
coup nos matchs il ne faut pas les
techniques des fragments ou alors tout
ça je loupé la télé qu'est ce qu'il ya
au programme ce soir
ah oui mon message sur les yaourts
mongol rené mars la prof ça va du
tournage je voudrais pas d'effrayer mais
tu sais ce qu'il est en train de nous
faire l'europe se campe sicot pédagogie
nous appelons une crise d'agressivité à
caractère destructeur hostile je vais
partir marque de cache pas que ça peut
aller très loin c'est une névrose qui a
déjà poussé des adolescents disons le au
meurtre et comme ton fils a
manifestement choisi tommy pour cible tu
comprendras mon inquiétude je vais
partir me thibout citigroup de réagir je
te propose de produire des peuples
étaient reçus car c'est un psychiatre
remarquable qu'elle adore je fais partie
martin tu vas quoi
tout ça pour acapulco aux écoutes mais
c'est très sérieux
je t'assure que toufik d'accord mon fils
va tout mais thomas et comme je ne veux
pas voir ça je pars pour un cacou la
forme pleine santé liman est encore
jeune et pas si mal foutu tiens j'ai
encore perdu deux kilos
d'abord marqué 6 mai le revenant tu n'as
pas remarqué ni toi ni personne je
m'évertue à perdre les kilos pour mon
armoire à glace
nous ne disons pas des tiges rêve par
l'odyssée très bien d'un robe de mariage
pique un peu tout le monde le trouve
magnifique qui ça tout le monde le 12
nov jérôme thomas laurent mois que le
monde est peuplé piqué ou plumetis je
t'en prie aime quoi tu te maries une les
mains se dit forte chérie tu ne perdra
jamais claude casion d'émailler par
quelques moments grandioses
le patchwork de ton existence c'est tout
j'ai encore trois mois devant moi pour
plancher sous-marin pas moi moi il faut
que je sois fixé avant lundi avant lundi
17h15 qu'est ce que c'est que cet
ultimatum
mon avion décolle lundi à 17h cazaute on
a dit vraiment 20 martin je peins je
file je ris je me taille quelle verve
emploi tu as la maternelle pour leur
faire comprendre ça à tes gosses de
quatre ans aux postures les questions
parole géraud jérôme comme s'il pouvait
abandonner la promotion des produits
n'est pas pauvre 13 ans tout cela je qui
se lavera mois blanc qui part comme ça
tout seul pourquoi tout seul je ne suis
pas pestiférés mais alors avec qui jouer
avec mon amant bien sûr
oh ouais je la tête avec ton amant bien
sûr je savais combien cette nouvelle ne
réjouira ma chérie tu parles sonnez
trompettes nhat hanh à mameui un amant
une valise des petits cachets de faux
termine enfin tout ce qu'il faut pour
faire le tour du monde dans les
meilleures conditions
à peine exagéré oui tu as raison d'un
iota mine étant trop continue notes
continuent
il m'a téléphoné ce matin un bon le coup
de téléphone c'était s'était tue ces
dates il en faudrait peu pour que tu ne
me crois pas ce serait nouveau ce n'est
jamais menti j'ai un amour jaloux
patience et riton tous reviendront mais
c'est pas du tout ce que je veux dire à
quoi que n'entre pas au quart nightmare
yves 9,1 at il s'agit de toi mais toi
nat ce n'est pas possible en l2 encore
en je veux dire que ce n'est pas
possible dans le contexte de son
intériorité
la psychologue la trappe qui te permet
de dresser l'inventaire de ce qu'il est
possible de ce qui ne l'est pas et
nathan 3 vous pourrez tomber dans tes
propres tiroirs et n'essaie pas de
crocheter les biens ce sont mes tiroirs
et je suis seul habilité à savoir ce
qu'il ya dedans
rien que du possible
au respect des cinq dernières secondes
quand j'enregistre ont brandi son
attaquant alors là j'aurais cru qu'ils
allaient fendre le moujik en deux et pas
te fait sauter le couvercle du pot de
yaourt saisis soit cédé à programmer
alors le prochain spot
car pour laver les taches de sang qui
ont giclé sur sap ou de mammouth veut
tuer la femme d'abel afin de lui piquer
son paquet de lessive bio tonique à 12
je ne vous dévoile pas la fin c'est le
grand choc à paris le sursis et à la
marie ce n'est pas capable ou non
acapulco la promotion du jour on sait y
faire jérôme durand recevra peut-être
bientôt des cartes postales
qu'est ce que tu veux dire bientôt mais
j'ai besoin de me changer les idées
qu'elle s'y des maris vont avoir sur toi
et oui comme young personne n'est pas je
n'ai pas de conseil à te donner jérôme
mais quand même si tu pouvais intéressé
au coup de téléphone que n'a pas reçu ce
matin
un coup de téléphone un coup de
téléphone
vaut mieux 4 coup de vieux
si votre virilité vous pensent des
problèmes
un coup de téléphone à 1010 le
spécialiste rihanna ksiri or merci gérer
non le magicien jeune enfant paje
non merci louis marty avec thomas se
tailla pas or ils vont encore montré à 2
heures du matin le majeur sherin
vieilles inquiétudes de ce rennais et
anti-fn en trois mois n'habitera plus
nous c'est vrai comment vas tu faire
pardon sans fans à la maison mais comme
en cent femmes aux excuses moi j'ai
senti un chapitre clos à propos de
chapitres ça y est je les trouvais un
peu le slogan pour les collants chapitre
chapitre le chapitre de l'inde et
maniable qui vous fera madame la jambe
aimable ouais ça n'a pas l'air de
pousser à la conservation
c'est à cette heure ci les magasins sont
fermés alors quoi de neuf aujourd'hui
chéri à les militaires ont pris le
pouvoir commence ici la radio l'a
annoncé tantôt dans un flash seulement
pour te dire où le nom du pays s'est
perdu dans une marque de déodorant et
dans laquelle je pense que je te
demander ce qui concerne ce qui me tue à
exister sinon en garde si tu commences à
me gonfler avec des actions pareilles tu
vas vite se sentir à l'étroit au mas
comment je tiens à ce que tu existes
chéri mentir à temps au plongeon de
toujours c'est d'eux que nous abordions
le sujet si ce maquillage coup de
téléphone que tu as reçu ce matin
franchement un seul neurone lie part ii
et rooney encore un événement de ta vie
qui passe au dessus
enfin quand je dis un événement ainsi si
tu te le dis on marque loin de moi
l'idée que tu interroges de là dessus
comme tu le dit c'est toi même ça
n'intéresse personne
mais rien de savoir que tu as reçu un
coup de téléphone ça me rassure je me
dis bon
ces journées sont prospectives et
promotion de sa vie elle fait ceci est
très soul al assouad écoute téléphone
elle exige te croire existent chérie je
te demande pas plus je crois que je vais
me résoudre à la bonne
et bien comme ça nous n'aurons pas perdu
notre soirée elle va bien qui ça dans
gertrude au bon je suppose que oui tu es
là les papilles and more et téléphonie
avancée par m
non moi ça m'a refroidi
ouais laure marchal ancien tons chair
tout dans le commerce comme ça histoire
d'avoir des nouvelles de son art rhioui
mieux merci à pâques tante gertrude dans
l'annuaire
j'ai la même que dans la nuit à 100 par
les bonnes femmes du monde ni les bons
hommes
ah tiens tiens c'était un homme tu
brûles voyez vous ça j'aime surtout ne
me dis pas qu'ils laissent pas deviner
l'amande madame banon du trip hop c'est
martin qui tu l'as dit tu te rends
compte qu'on peut être jeune l'âge
fortifie la jeunesse sur ce qu'il
raconte antoine antoine oui ton oncle
antoine excuse moi dans ce matin au
téléphone téléphone alors ça aurait très
bien pu être l'oncle antoine vos métiers
conscient de ce que tu dis pourquoi
réfléchi nous convenons ensemble que
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone de l'
oncle antoine et alors tu en déduit que
c'est mon amant je sais bien que
l'époque on a vu d'autres en fait
monsieur même pour une idiote et des
limites au bo a su ça détend
amusons-nous bien de ce soir franchement
j'ai eu une de ces journées quatre
heures de discussions rien croit
produits de massage qui sait la colline
ce truc pour les mains donc bien série à
qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient ton
d'embarquer pour acapulco décidément je
n'ai rien à t'apprendre acapulco le mot
de passe de la famille autant s'en
servir
naturellement tu sais aussi que je pars
lundi à mais bien sûr tu pars lundi si
le métro n'est pas en grève je pars
lundi j'ai j'entends bien pour acapulco
avec mon amant qui n'est pas ton oncle
et qui n'est pas non plus du goût
alors si maintenant on jouait à col
touazi je compte jusqu'à voir je te
cherche compte trois jours et cherche
moi nat
oui tu vois quand même le dire quitte à
téléphoner je perds la tête
c'était mon amant figure-toi remarque
j'ai bien essayé de lui faire le coup du
faux numéros ultime résistance d'une
femme de droit mais bien entendu ça n'a
pas pris tu pensé de la connais ma voix
nous sommes ensemble c'est toujours moi
qui parle il dit que m'avoir sangamo
n'at il ne sentait plus il dit des tas
de choses comme ça tient ou toujours
dire je trouve une petite mine mois
depuis quelques temps
tu me regardes ça c'est normal tu te
regarderai si je ne faisais pas bonne
question
non non non non non non je voulais dire
c'est mon devoir devoir bien entendu que
pour être faire d'autre mais un homme de
devoir jusqu'au bout d'aisé alors ça a
l'air de te fais ton devoir
regarde moi et ben écoute nat une petite
mine visite
oui à tel point que je me demande s est
dit vas-y tu devrais pas aller passer
trois quatre jours chez la cousine
armande à plouézec
pour l'histoire d'avaler un bol d'air
avec une paille
ça te ferait le plus grand bien je
t'assure la proposition m'émeut
profondément pas les plongeurs ont rien
si je dirais même plus je t'en veux
presque des regrets que tu me donnes
parce que franchement ratée plouézec
pour acapulco
bon alors si tu permets jouer le coucher
voudrais-tu déposer mon oreiller sur le
divan de la chambre d'amis dont lauriers
je ris correcteurs réveillant venant
chercher moi-même tout à l'heure oui
mais pour quoi faire
kouadio ton oreiller pour poser ma tête
dessus série oui mais pourquoi dans la
chambre d'amis parce que sur le divan de
la chambre d'amis il n'y a pas de riez
est-ce que tu essaies de me faire
comprendre que tu va coucher dans la
chambre d'amis mais je n'essaie pour un
shérif c'est tellement évident que tu
l'as compris tous ses vols low cost
cutting prend et comment ce qui me prend
je ne peux tout de même pas que je
pourrai coucher avec toi maintenant que
tu sais que j'ai un amant jetons plein
de prière n'y feront rien j'ai ma
dignité moi c'est tout noir couture et
insistait par chery maintenant qu'il est
prouvé que tu sais ce que tu as eu
l'obligeance de docteur je me taise
c'est bien ce que tu me demandes
exactement sa natte que je me taise
motus et tout rentre dans leur voie là
franchement jérôme pour qu'ils me
prendre je ne me pose pas te le dis
comment peux-tu croire même en me
connaissez aussi peu que tu me connais
enfin tu as voulu on a que j'accepterais
de noyer le poisson donc sinon le
poisson dans le silence rapporte quoi
que je puisse être complice de sa
surdité volonté et les plus de 10
on a de ton aveuglement complaisant et
comment tu croire ça l'heure n'est pas
aux questions chérif est profondément ta
mort et toi tu es complètement folle ça
y est le mot que j'ai tourné bas ne
l'attend plus il devenu folle ça
t'arrange reste à voir comment dont la
belle excuse elle me trouve parce
qu'elle est folle mais du compte pas
jérôme tout est à sa place là dedans et
tu n'as aucune exploit bon dieu
excusable jérôme du n'est pas un mari
trompé son mari qui sert icône at
rittaud rideau va déposer mon oreiller
sur le divan de la chambre relève en toi
par la masse et sa touchante et va le
déposer toi même te prend par la main
ma bien aimée par ta main blanche comme
les ailes de la colombe douce il
faudrait est nu comme
rama l'ange comme l'ale de la colombe
douce et fraîche et nu comme l'amour
grâce à la colline le lait de jouvence
des mains amoureux voilà
en quoi est ce que tu vois ce que tu
fais et bah quoi je me tiens droit
penche toi
faudrait savoir ce que tu veu t pas au
courant par hasard de ce qu'il a pas
comment ça ce qu'il a une maladie
contagieuse ou quelque chose de chauffe
ce que tu racontes moment a dormi dans
la chambre d'amis même qu'il y est
encore commencé tout ça ben cette nuit
j'ai entendu remuer alors ce matin j'ai
glissé à l'oeil bravo un micro dans le
pot de fleurs ça sera parfait
on sort commence c'est quand même
bizarre non des moments dans la chambre
d'amis moi tu t'en fou quoi tant qu'il
ne s'agit pas le topic et 1 116 écoute
toi si tu continues à poursuivre
automates à une pathologie hausse à ces
extras alors lequel poursuit l'autre
gelé sur les rangs le meurtre le jeudi
le samedi
il me tombe dessus pendant les
intercours il met à 7 à la sortie on
ressemble on bouffe ensemble le matin
elle vient me chercher comme ça lui
suffit pas de le persécuter en tant que
prof
ils te poussent pour devenir voulons que
le travail des tartines ça empêchera des
âneries de sortir je peux pas déjà
debout un oui non plus une valeur et
osier ça se taillent aux aurores qu
est-ce que l or mais tu as toi droit
il est temps café non mais c'est je vais
déjà pris qu'est-ce que je me sente
ennuierait tous penchés
vitraux que j'ai des mots que je me
défoule
pourquoi je n'aurais 12,6 pencher si le
droit
tu vas bien papa pourquoi me demande tu
ça comme ça pour se voir mais pour
savoir quoi
ben si tu vas bien bah je vais très bien
je te remercie ah bon sacrée pierre
si seulement il pouvait faire son deuil
ailleurs que sur thomas des pipettes
thomas non il est à dire un pied de
profs qui parlementent avec un q
d'élèves ça débouche parfois sur un
compromis intéressant ce n'est pas la
méthode de thomas si on a une eau qui
s'en servent après tout c'est lui
tiennent dans la famille c'est à 8
séduit un bon jeu finir mes rosiers
jérôme oui si tu éprouvent le besoin de
me parler ne te gêne pas mais en quel
honneur cette généreuse invite au a3 à
eybens l'embase y étale voiture et
emmenée au moins à fond hasard si je
n'ai ni acapulco
ça te fait penser à quoi aux mondiaux
comme que nous pourrons peut-être
changer nos conneries pour jérôme
excellent réflexe sa peau souvent mais
pour tout dire je craignais que tu que
je fais là n'en parlons plus puisque
tant qu'infirmier du froid écoute jérôme
s'il fallait une preuve rassurant gelé
le coin une preuve
je comprends pas la bay of matin j'ai
consultés m'ont wellington donc ouais
elle est traitée du professeur
wellington sur l'inconscient un stock de
gènes
c'est drôlement fortifiant ça surtout un
jeu commence pas au volant bonbons à
layton alors alors il est clair que
l'intérêt go de nattes correspond au
troisième archétypes peu défini par
wellington celui où la dynamique du
réservoir d'instinct s'oppose
systématiquement à toute velléité de
compensation par prosper et rongera je
te demandais de me faire un cro q et
bien selon washington les analytiques
mans impossible que la tomate bac est
satisfait que l'histoire d'acapulco jeu
coup de téléphone tout ça tout ça
5 fixation d'imago par imaginative
wallington bixi qui voit ses traits
tu permets que je te gifle sur
présentation du livret de famille ça te
paraît dumas de plongée nat dans ce
bouillon de culture je vous laisse faire
le joint de ça pour la connaître moi
battu par maman alors c'est pour toi
jérôme pour te rassurer me rassurez moi
mais tu te portes bien du canton voit la
vulnérabilité du psychisme mal de
ballons passante est tout seul thomas
avec tes livres de chevet est comme moi
bien nate et jérôme c'est ça
quinze ans de confiance et depuis le
premier jour
alors ils te dire que pour arracher sa
et comme avec des fariboles
ça nous amuse pas elle joue ses flancs
buste assure vous savez pas mais il faut
la voir l'été au casino de cabourg a
tranché à la roulette essayant tous les
soirs de faire sauter la banque
avec 20 ans et a repris avec ça quand
elle comme son dernier show elle savane
le croupier et le copier hier soir ce
témoin bien savonné je suis pour au
décapant quand elle a vu qu'elle perdait
sa mise tu sais ce qu'elle a fait une
chambre à part
pardon martin me disais que lorsque vous
seriez mariée elle ferait chambre à part
ce n'est pas vrai seul pour moi que nous
donner l'occasion de tester la
vulnérabilité de son psychisme ma
chambre a peur bourgeoise qui part
c'est un dicton de mon pays est exact
diary de remarquables que dans un couple
la force de rupture avec une famille
walker comme d'habitude bon alors le
temps de passer une jupe laurent est
prêt je leur amène par les cheveux
édition nous verra porter offre en
volleyball a dit le dicton chambre a pas
de café non le matin voici le chocolat
il est remarquable que dans un couple en
instance de rupture en vo non pardon au
chocolat en poudre nom en bas je fais
fondre que dans un couple instance d'une
rupture dans du lait pardon le chocolat
en bas vous le faites fondre dans du
lait vous y voyez un inconvénient ou
séries 10 mois qu'il sait peau que la
vie est courte et qu'on s'en fout mal
collectivement
avez-vous bien dormi comme une femme qui
a fait chambre à part
ah bon parce que vous avec du sucre
pardon
le chocolat en bas avec tout ce que oui
sûrement fenêtre c'est un dicton
positivement dans du lait pardon avec
une chute mais combien de sucre tout
dépend de la nature du chocolat au bac
est fréquemment son talent pour marquer
le fait est qu'il est déjà bien dommage
ce dicton mais non chez renault soient
pas industrie très discret à mai mais
pas du tout net c'est indique-t-on chez
moi qui dis ma chambre à part bourgeoise
qui par notre belle humeur me fait envie
thomas expliquez-moi le comique de la
simple relation de cause à effet nat
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que vous
aviez dormi comme une femme qui a fait
chambre à part
alors moi en application de ce jeu vous
imaginez pliant suppliant bagages et en
somme une idée que je puisse alors ça
vraiment aussi réalisables qu'une
équation tridôme par un cheval de bois
et comment vous représentez vous les
femmes qui est très simple dit voir de
tous les genres nat sauf du votre
réforme de l'enseignement le ministre
supprime les maths dans le programme de
troisième à ozanam bijoux comme je
souhaitais mieux bas que ce soit vrai ah
bah oui je n'ai rien révisé j'ai tout
oublié je suis creux comme un radis
parfaite unité il est il de venir en
classe et bien qu est ce que tu vas t'en
retourne dans ton pieux pas dit jusqu'à
ton prof que le permet il veut se
débarrasser de moi oui mais j'ai le
regret j'ai l'habitude croit plus
encombrant que tu ne pas un dit tout de
suite que je suis quantité négligeable
pour une fois tu as compris le problème
éventuel renfort satisfaite de telle
série
très comme les miens ne l'ont fait plus
les gens pourront avoir une de tes
blagues ma grande qu'on passe un bon
week-end à ce soir à ce soir s'allume
pas salut fis ce n'est pas malade moi
j'en ai l'air non pas du tout non
pourquoi cette question par prudence
vaut mieux prévenir que guérir j't'adore
sais comment que je viens pas encombrant
vous allez voir
[Musique]
ce matin j'ai greffer une pompadour sur
un empereur de chine
rozier matinée historia au job la route
une fois de temps en temps refaire
l'histoire en donner un peu d'imprévu à
tous à tous ce que ça se prennent ce
dont on connaît la fin dieu merci tout
n'est pas écrit
pas écrit mais vécue et alors c'est la
même chose ce qui est vécu est écrit
de l'audace refaisons l'histoire que
dirais tu pour midi d'un veau marengo
avec des croûtons talent je m'étais plus
chez les oignons et pas trop casion que
les oignons pour pleurer sur ma mère et
s est félicité l photo comprendra
déduction elle n'a pas d'autre occasion
que les options pour pleurer sur elle
même donc elle est heureuse du je suis
heureuse ça gagne du temps le temps qui
reste à soi ce précieux reliquat du
temps qu'on ne s'écrit fier aux autres
qu'est ce que tu chantes je suis heureux
voilà ça me fait plaisir
vraiment je suis un peu pour quelque
chose non non
à te fais toujours là je saute de joie
reviens moi j'ai défoncé le plafond tu
pensais vraiment profité je suis
heureuse d'un portefeuille ce qui
t'intéresse dans mon bonheur c'est toi
tu as pensé longtemps pour finir les 7 3
olala latifi par depuis hier je
fonctionne en accéléré mais il faut bien
deux jours je tiens vraiment à remettre
ça remettre quoi je n'ai rien à retirer
écoute et inquiète pas mon chéri ça ne
m'empêchera pas de te mitonné ton
marengo avec des croûtons ne fait pas
semblant sortir tout bon alors à tort
va-t-il des foules toi joue un bon coup
à l'apprentie sorcière et qu'on en
finisse
vraiment je ne saisis pas bah si tu ne
saisis pas assez grave qui va saisir
risquons tout de même pas sur moi pour
t'expliquer les bizarreries ton
comportement parce que tu trouve tout ce
que je peux te dire c'est qu'à force
d'appeler le diable pour fini par s'en
oui je ne voudrais pas de fixer mais je
préfère nettement les dictons deux tomes
on appuyait le sait les étranges heures
dehors de mes parents étrangers tombeau
frais futur peut-être et si ça se trouve
tu l'as dis toi même
tout n'est pas écrit pro choix d'aller
lui raconter tes exploits de cette nuit
délicieusement thomas comme une femme
qui a fait chambre à part
mais franchement de quoi ai-je l'air
mais chérie tu n'es pas concernés c'est
moi pas concernés eh ben tu vois tu
toujours partout enfin réfléchi deux
secondes quand à longueur d'année tuna
de prévenance que pour les poudre à
récurer d'admiration que pour les vertus
des déodorants
quand ton esprit bondé de messages ou
spot affiche complet au point que je n'y
puis trouver le moindre strapontin
quand en un mot depuis 15 ans à
l'exception de nouvelles rencontres
quotidiennes et strictement épidermique
nous faisons vie à pas est ce que je te
demande moi mais j'ai non
je ne suis pas concerné voilà pourquoi
on éprouverait du dépit je ne sais
quelle humiliation étant concernée par
ailleurs je considère que nous sommes
qui pourront venir attendant je me fou
d'autant bas laisse sa tranquille
concernés par ailleurs ça veut dire quoi
refaisons l'histoire hier matin version
un coup de téléphone sur la terre on
écoute j'ai renoncé remué par ailleurs
ça veut dire quoi
ledit 16h30 à l'aéroport salon de thé
deuxième étage ah non ça c'est pas
possible cher il a dit je suis prêt mais
les affaires et vasicek temps gertrude
val traîne un peu la patte mais elle
adore le thé ou mieux encore à ton
fantôme du téléphone bonne occasion de
l'emploi
jérôme stoll cesse de me considérer
comme une sous développés regarde moi
pour une fois tels que je suis prend le
temps d'ouvrir là que tu vas être étonné
tiens tu vois je ne suis pas
transparente
j'ai même des couleurs et du relief
qu'est ce que tu dit ça et ce n'est pas
tout je brûle aussi et je parle
apparemment de manière si on sait
puisque même toi tu sembles comprendre
ce que je dis et je respire
mais d'autres choses encore en fait j'ai
la complexité d'un être vivant
crois-tu ce qu'on ne fait pas de nos
jours
je ne porte en outre aucun poulet aucune
entrave tu peux vérifier parfaitement
libre oui alors l'avion pour acapulco
l'école lundi à 17h15 chazel pas vrai
l'accès au palais tranquille je le fous
par la fête du canada
ce n'est vrai nom explique moi tes
certitudes
tu parles explique moi le met au milieu
de la figure
c'est analytiquement impossible
parfaitement à cause de taux d'intérêt
go la dynamique de ces instants sont pas
systématiquement au réservoir de thé
velléités par transfert de compensation
tout ça n'est que imago et compagnie
doublée d'une fixation de l'imaginatif
voilà vingt ans que je demande à martine
non inutile quand c'est elle qui le dit
c'est pas plus clair
on a j'aimerais bien te faire plaisir
faire semblant de croire tout dedans
tellement mal c'est bien le dire après
tout pourquoi pas sur des choses qui
arrivent ça les fans très bien marier
avec qui peut très bien alors pourquoi
pas un autre femme très bien d'un titre
elle enfin pas mal mais chaque fois que
je me pose la question les réponses qui
viennent son objection votre objection
votre honneur et ton fils laurent tu
l'emmènes non alors tu l'abandonnent
comme ça froidement sa sensibilité
exacerbée
à l'âge où les gars ont le plus besoin
de leur mère aux risques de l'ue
provoque un traumatisme incurable
névrose dont il souffre a toute sa vie
pauvre monde
eh ben dis quelque chose je peux
remporter le ballet non bras c'est quoi
cette une est obligé ton fils c'est
comme un mariage d'état selon le
fauteuil dans ton histoire et la
cuisinière havre à auch tu vas de
l'année commenté m et le carrelage de la
salle de battue va surveiller les
carreleurs par télépathie et le plant de
tomate dans ton jardin donc plants de
tomates
tu va le laisser pourrir et moi ben oui
moi qu'est-ce que tu deviendrais sans
moi oui je pense qu'il te reste plus
qu'à rire c'est un big tonka nul à un
sacré bi ondemand ce que ça va donner
quoi d'où la pompadour et l'empereur de
chine des cornes admis qu'un
à propos n'as tu ne m'as toujours pas
dit qui tu avais téléphoné hier matin
[Applaudissements]
quand même quelque chose qui m'échappe
le nez pincé entre le pouce et l'index
de la main droite bon qui vivent dans
cette position respirons régulièrement
vos cheveux avaient dû faire mouche
[Musique]
yoga des débutants et débutants sakhir
ma parole angers coûterait laquelle fait
une fois par jour ça suffira roczen 0%
de matière grasse au un régime à lui
tout seul
joli tas plates bandes après à tan tan
c'est chic dans les doigts ma grand la
haute couture ne saura jamais ce qu'elle
a perdu partie la plaque non ne touche
pas aux archives j'ai vu ça fait de la
poussière du sénat j'y pense souvent je
serais incapable moi de tout balancer
comme tu l'as fait la libye n'a
peut-être que je n'aime pas suffisamment
de stocks
ben quoi c'est bien pour jérôme bouba
n'ont jamais rien pour idiote à cause de
l'eau à cause de quoi
parce qu'il concerne tu tiens je me
documente à à la varicelle de laurent
haut à mon avenir était inscrit dans les
boutons de mon fils tu te souviens du
cinéma djhero la trompette du désespoir
des mois je vous dis que ce n'est pas
une varicelle ordinaire le plus émouvant
s'est passé dans notre chambre
une nuit entière à me persuader que
c'était de ma faute on n'abandonne pas
un gosse de 4 entre les mains d'une
bonne pleine de millas corollaire
inévitable
tu sacrifies son office attaque amiel
sur leurs célèbres du taratata
je suis fort capable de subvenir seule
aux besoins de ma famille figure toi tu
sais l'honneur à vis du 15 tonnes qui te
bouffe l'oxygène je roule pour vous du
reste ta carrière ma pour furie
parlons-en ta carrière ma pauv' ce même
amour fou rire en toi conte tacle arias
bousses à ma peau ferry dans le chiffon
même apport furie la création mode
ah ah c'est bien autre chose ah ah dans
l'autre
j'avais ton âge je vais sûrement vous
matin j'ai donné congé à lachen cela dit
pat roy anthony le miserere c'est pas la
bonne qui faillit bourgeois alors
nouvelle allons tous les quatre ces deux
fleurons de la race humaine que vous
étiez laurent et toi
le routier roulant désormais seul pour
nous et la pauvreté enfin plus long ses
meubles confort design à crédit mais pas
une traite en star planning programme in
budget tignes disons le mot une réussite
et l'amour dans tout ça dans chéri non
c'est le contraire tout ça dans l'amour
alors pourquoi n'en parle pas et parce
que ce sont les yeux qui font l'omelette
pas le panier bien eu agression c'est
pour toi tu mets pas l'emporter au
mexique
mr
car avec ça toute la matinée ça suffit
peut-être non justement j'ai
l'impression que ça ne suffit pas enfin
n'a franchement ça mène à quoi sans en
avoir l'air à la forme c'est sale
invitera bonne mine
j'en connais qui vont se payer sa tête
pour pas cher je te préviens je ne serai
pas la dernière a sauté sur les sols
film at war plus 25 ans tu l'as monaco
les à la langue de qui s'agit-il pas là
mais non ça ne va pas je veux savoir qui
tu fréquentes
qu'est ce qui te pourra fabriquer ce qui
lui prend à celle là ainsi maintenant la
commode se met à poser des questions
lorsque j'ai entendu ça mais quelle
époque que tout allait si bien le
tic-tac de l'horloge et plus de poisson
rouge le ronron du frigidaire et
violoncelle latif lang son sabot dans la
mécanique à qui se fier seulement je te
jure na qui me fait peur tu vois sherin
a tu te fais peur voilà ce que c'est que
de ne pas s'interroger sur ses
fréquentations
donc ça marche ça roule là bonjour toc
un drôle de petit bruit sous le capot
mon stop on est là qu est ce qu on
trouve vraiment monstre dans le moteur à
la pire que sa chérie nat avec une
valise à la main du ciel d'où sort tu
toi bats comme tous les samedis monde du
rugby club municipal
tu as servi de ballon
ce serait trop beau chez nous quand le
ballon reçoit un coup de pied dont lui
présente des excuses
enfin puisque tu aimes ça j'ai jamais
dit que j'aimais ça c'est papa qui dit
remarque il a sans doute raison qu'il
faudrait être complètement taré pour se
mettre dans des états pareils sans
savoir la foi ou coupe tu allais moment
un jour tu as tout finira par tous
coincés là pour tirer pas quoi un jour
quand le droit de savoir on a droit
légitime chez ricoh 99 pas l'intention
assieds toi mon trésor ne crois pas
qu'il aurait plutôt besoin d'aller
prendre une douche bon tout de suite
médiation je choisis mon écoute mon âge
fait un homme maintenant aux chouettes
drôle de choc pourquoi pas lui qui a mis
dix ans format plus petit qu elle ton
père est un sentimental gérer je ne sais
pas le dire mais toi et moi nous savons
que tu es un homme n'est ce pas je te
fais confiance moment
alors voilà suppose que je m'en aille où
ça peu importe que je mens nike je
quitte la maison pourquoi cette gêne que
ce soit l'homme venant mon bijou ça n'a
aucun rapport le fait que tu sois un
homme mois seulement te permettre de
comprendre et comprendre quoi c'est que
je m'emmerde
mais pour quoi faire écoute mon fils la
vie je veux non plus tôt dans la vie ou
si tu préfères l'existence l'existence
des paroles on en écoute voilà mon
chalet suppose que tu t'en ailles
d'accord je suppose tu t'en vas tu es
parti et alors ça ne te gêne pas robin
thicke quand t'es pas là ça fait un
creux un creux ben oui tiens les deux
jours où tu as là marseille pour
l'enterrement de mon parrain rubin ici
c'était pas la joie
qu'est-ce qu'on l'a bouffé que ma vie
dure aux armes
non c'est pareil à mon honneur tu parles
de la mayonnaise en turban pour chatons
avec ton fois délicat
enfin bref faut bien enterrer les gens
si tu pars tu es tu aurais tu es raison
ce serait pas pour ton plaisir
certainement pas mon ange se serait
pourquoi alors pour mon bonne ton quoi
bonheur ton bonheur oui je sais il ya
des mots qui surprennent bon supposons
qu'ils partiraient pour longtemps ça tu
connais la der à agen on sait quand on
part tous d'accord mais tout de même il
faut une hypothèse de travail
yach if we joue 15 trois semaines un
mois on est diminué mais faut pas
pousser votre dada moi je peux supposer
moins imaginatif mais quand elle même
local entend en tout conscient
inaccessibles sans prix toi on doit
encore sickology de labour edward mais
bon sujet mesdames que disions-nous la
question de bonne
alors comme d'habitude au cinéma
documentaire internet support mais quel
bonheur
le mien chéri pièces uniques bail alors
ton bonheur il est dit sinon suppose que
non
en support suppose ce cas pas debout je
suis pas ton bonheur moi tu es la
prunelle de mes yeux et ben qu'est ce
que tu veux de plus
rien chéri côté prunelle ça va j'en ai
même deux autres au secours
t'es sûr que je suis un homme moment je
suis vachement optimiste pourquoi parce
qu'on prend rien ce que tu le dit marc
lapointe broc mais ça va venir ne
t'énerve pas cool enfin quoi tu pourrais
être heureuse sans moi supposant mais il
faudra d'abord supposer que tu ne
m'aimes pas je vais tout d'amour alors
tu es refaite et tout fait n'est pas
précisément un signe de béatitude mon
nom je prends l'une où je suis oyez
bonnes gens
la prunelle de mes yeux va prendre une
douche un oui moi je prends des douches
ou petit amour propre ce sera toujours
ça écoute moment déjà papa m'oblige à
mascate et les chevilles dans cette
saleté de rugby qui doit en plus tu te
même tabassé les ménages et ben moi les
jours ouvrables que je fasse des
matières non event sauvetage d'un
problème pour problème pourtant que ce
soit ce nouveau programme
conclusion mon bonheur ne te concerne
pas mais me concerne si je suis dedans
un maintien on n'a qu'à l'ombre et 1
quant à faire le moindre sacrifice je
suis pas ton père après la trouve
l'argument majeur irréfutable tu n'es
pas mon père tout et larbin oui oui le
fait que je sois heureuse ne saurait en
aucun cas être considérée par mon fils
qu'est ce qu'ils ont à [ __ ] tout
heureuse si moi je ne suis pas au revoir
simone ça madame bipèdes homo sapiens
est tout prêt à vous mitonner discipline
de ses qualités de la voûte moment va
prendre sa douche dans quatre ans tu
votes
je voudrais voir
intéressant non tu ne croyez tout de
même pas qu'ils allaient engager à
partir le shérif c'est ce qu'il a fait
puis après tout de quoi je me mêle marre
de toute façon dans quelques semaines
oui ça tombe bien
bien mal chacun sa vie je m'occupe de la
mienne et basterds tombera soit loué
si ma présence de peser tant fallait le
dire plus tôt je serais allé vivre
ailleurs on pardonne moi chérie je suis
d'une ingratitude sais pas du tout ce
que je voulais dire si si je me rends
compte tout à coup du sacrifice que tu
as fait en restant je voulais seulement
ton enfance et un jeu nes et tout fait
dans mont cotton pour ce trésor
je ne te reproche rien tu devrais quand
je pense à ce que tu as envie de toi
même pour enrichir mon existence je t'en
prie et la diversité été grassement dans
trouve l appétit était adorable migraine
le chat le terme de serre et moi que
profiter de ce pactole comme de la chose
la plus naturelle du monde avec un
éclair cinat merci pour tout merci merci
merci encore un shérif
en tout cas sont visiblement pas mon
avenir qui l'inquiète salon tracé comme
il est commencé à tracer ma part comme à
semble-t-il thomas pau demain à quoi il
est bien placé pour qui si ça ne marche
pas avec tu m'as fait il bah oui ce sont
des choses qui arrivent
qu'est ce que je fais si ça ne marche
pas je retourne chez qui qu'est ce qui n
a rien rien c'est l'émotion à prendre
comme ça d'un seul coup que tu m'avais
mise en réserve de ta petite république
mais kuna tant attendu chez moi
reprendre souffle mais enfin ma blonde
c'est normal mais non chérie c'est
sublime
mais voilà face à de grandes espérances
quand je ne serai que pour ça on devoir
être resté pour devoir est de rester
pour des tas de raisons de voir le
devoir ça existe nord si comme la trame
de la pluie quand on commence à
l'apercevoir il est temps d'en changer
stupéfiant l'inimaginable vient de se
produire et qui plus est chez moi ça m'a
bien de gagner la partie poule sans
aucun mérite je tire en fermant les yeux
assez bon ça je me disais bien vous
aviez tricher
en tapant bray de manoeuvres dilatoires
n'a pas l'air d'inspirer les foules
maquoy le bridge stratégie du bâillon
silence il ya un mort de quoi rassurer
une autre russe même approché je ne suis
pas inquiet je ne me suis pas inquiet
raison d'insister c'est un message
important votre futur beau frère n'est
pas inquiet thomas oui c'est très c'est
généralement la preuve que d'un bon
équilibre mental tu vas chéri vraiment à
lui n'a pas besoin de calcium aux fêtes
jérôme vous êtes il fait part de mes
intentions
c'est à dire que tu penses j'ai fait
sauter dans l'humour de la famille à
pieds joints sa l'amusement
en somme vous aussi thomas joris et d'un
bon équilibre mental la fois inquiet
pour deux sous pourquoi ne serais-je
épouse martine il me semble que c'est
mathématique
j'épouse la tornade blanche qui dissout
tout motif d'inquiétude donc ça jérôme
ça vaut de l'or mais je tiens à dire que
je pousse bertino toute confiance et
corollairement parce que je la crois
capable de incapable de boire mais dur
méfie-toi thomis et y met en doute mes
capacités le blanchit s'effondre
incapable de quoi
de quoi me crois tu y es incapable
incapable n'est peut-être pas le terme
exact mais exprime toi tommy n'ai pas
peur nous sommes en démocratie je te
crois capable de pas mal de choses et
même d'à peu près tout pourquoi cette
restriction
oui c'est vrai nous et comme tu l'aide
de touché mais c'est tommy bien voilà
pourquoi attendre quinze ans pour mettre
au point ce genre de détails la crois
capable de tout perd 6 0 la prochaine
fois prendre à 6,35 lundi chéri pour le
baiser d'adieu
ne mettez pas en doute mes capacités ou
le plancher ses fonds 48km de liberté
pour la bonne réponse oui ou non échos
la lauréate six mois que tu ne dormira
plus que tu feras garden que tu t'es
freetrack que tu tournera en rond que tu
ne vivras plus que pour tuer le temps
que tu assassines aimant les uns de ses
parts en écrivant des points mais pour
sûr ça s'aggrave de minute en minute
il va faire quand on sort on vit toits
seront régis 3 c'est facile rien de ce
qui vaut la peine d'être vécue
les facile série souhaité
si facile ici 15 ans d'amour ah oui ça
surement d'amour et de chaleur
chaudières à fuel humaine aussi 37
degrés et le coeur bien sûr coeur
battant bon coeur bonjour bonsoir bonne
fête bons voeux
rien que du bon et le seul si tu ne
prendras froid ne prend pas chaud
traverse dans les clous que zoé tous ca
tiré au cordeau net honnête et propre
sous un toit parfaitement démange
éviterait plein sur l'effort chez le
téléphone quel privilège question madame
oui ou non
renoncer partie technique l'article que
je les aime comme il m'aime d'amour
oui sûrement tic tac tic tac tic tac tic
tac je vous aime j'arrive à mouzens
question à la wii ou non parce que chose
inouïe
quel sens va tout ça non plus empêcher
de telles femmes de sommeil tête à tête
à tête avec elle invite le temps pas le
temps oui c'est ça vous dit vous la
force plus fort que tout ça le temps qui
reste à soi voyez-vous ce précieux
relais cas du temps qu'on a sacrifié aux
autres frites madame vite oui non cinq
secondes quatre fois vingt secondes
oui la capote acapulco acapulco
il faut tout même que je vous dise prof
ce n'est pas tous les week-ends comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien dormez gérer mort fait soi même
pourquoi que c'est martine ne m'avait
pas réveiller lfs à sebourg pourront
apporter mon petit déjeuner au lit bon
brioches et croissants chauds sur
plateau d'argent et n'approuve de
dentelle ça surement un sens affectés
c'est dimanche
si je passais un petit coup sur la
moquette pas pour eux comme ça quoi
histoire d'honorer seigneur toutes
bonnes intentions laumord paraît-il
voiture mais jusqu'à maintenant
seulement utile martin y est déjà
ouais c'est déjà si dimanche si j'allais
au marché plongeant dans l'inédit à il
faut vivre avec son temps d'après
l'astrologue des galeries lafayette nous
sommes entrés dans l'ère du verseau
avait dit non je te signal à tout hasard
que cette semaine j'ai fait six fois le
ménage à fond et mais je n'ai aucune
illusion chaire est une sacrée veine si
j'arrive à connecter le gramme de
poussière symboliquement s'employer
là-bas au moins ça ou alors en quoi le
jeu sans oublier en couleurs je n'ai pas
ravir qu'une musique il a du coeur tu
vas ne sont plus que sexy en s'allumant
il fait beau ce matin les jeux wii vient
pas ici d'où sortent us a pas de la
machine à laver quoi faut que tu veux
dire je prête pour faire un roc
je suis entré par hasard dans la
buanderie et j'ai vu deux trois bricoles
qui traînait alors je me suis dit tiens
c'est dimanche s'il tenait à bouffer aux
enzymes
apparemment une crevette pas bon mais
rld
sa voile parents trésor on distingue
encore très bien la forme d'une chemise
excuse moi il faut que j'attende avant
que ça sèche les sur deux canaux
intéressante cette formule kibboutz
n'est ce pas moi qui me faisais du souci
du souci pour chery rassure toi ça a
fonctionné impeccable un vrai roulements
à billes tellement que dimanche prochain
pour nous rappeler que c'est parti on va
faire un le nôtre mouchoirs bravo g
roupe rien de tel que la bonne humeur
pour contrer la facture alors là je peux
faire des projets à long terme
je suis très content oui allez encore un
signe de bonne santé
content de kwame de ce qui t'arrive pas
bleu tu veux ça et je n'ai jamais été
plus sincères j'espère que tu me crois
puisque tu me le dis autant que j'en
profite
depuis quand pardon tu es content depuis
quand à deux puis trois heures trois
heures et quelques théories et
brusquement et blanc comme la flèche
cette fulgurance je suis contente ce qui
lui arrive
j'ai regardé ma montre il était 3 heures
et quelques mécaniques pile
insondable mystère des heures ouais
alors naturellement je cherchais à
comprendre à mesdames passé comme ça de
la crédulité dont faisait preuve hier
encore à cette sorte d' adhésion
spontanée je n'osais en faire la
remarque mais rassure toi j'ai compris
vite fait il a suffi d'une bonne analyse
objective et hop
ma pauvre chéri comment as tu fait pour
me supporter si longtemps question
troublante à ces qualités font tuer dieu
merci les qualités oui on s'assure de la
menue monnaie les mois passent à un
moellon mais je tue tout ce que tu
abandonnes un trésor est très
certainement des richesses d'intérieur
non ne rêve pas chérie ce que tu quittes
c'est une barrique de bourda conscience
de goujaterie de balourdise de vulgarité
d'un stade primaire brutaux cynique
incongrue du pire où l'euphorie de
survol tu perds mais quand je pense aux
monuments d'égoïsme que j'ai été disons
un petit en aparté non maîtres est allé
dans son existence comme j'en ai fait
sans pudeur sans scrupule avec
l'inconscience à mollusques encéphale
cardo - forme humaine le roi des poulpes
et voilà ce que je suis n'est l'on mène
au repas de gracieuses prévenu pendant
15 ans j'ai bouffé ton oxygène ouais bon
enfin quoi j'ai survécu est vraiment
apple siri apple en trois mois il était
temps que tu pars tu te remercie de me
faciliter les choses simples assistance
à personne en danger
et bien sûr tu vas me manquer tu sais ah
oui naturellement tu étais une victime
idéale parfaitement adapté à mon style
de tortue la manière de souffrir me
donner bonne conscience pour un bourreau
moyens ça compte
obama allait pas de nuages russell
d'acapulco c'est fantastique acapulco tu
sais craintes habitants la paire de la
côte mexicaine entre tech panne et y en
a pas devant toi l'océan pacifique avec
sa faute de poissons tropicaux tu te
retournes et qu'est ce que tu vois la
sierra madre d'elle sourdine aux mines
d'argent de plomb de cuivre de manganèse
sans parler du climat une hygrométrie
équilibrée au point de presse le paradis
des asthmatiques et et rhumatisante la
simple les indiens l'ont baptisé le
pied-à-terre du bon dieu tu te rends
compte veinarde
les indiens
sinon à propos la semaine prochaine tu
auras un régler la 4e mensualités de ton
encyclopédique
ah oui nous reste je déposerai un petit
mémoire sur ton bureau avec la date des
diverses échéant oui il faudra que je me
programme aussi à ce genre de détails
ton informatique et arts pour info ce
qu'il faut mais toute façon il y en a là
dedans la ressource non mais j'avais
lutté et puis après tout la terre et
petite personne neuf personnes tout au
plus on s'éloigne mais il y a des c à
saint louis où vas tu comment je vais je
reviens de l'hyper choc celui de tokyo a
tu peux rire j'ai passé une bonne partie
de la nuit à cauchemar de sujets de tes
bagages parce que les valises de ton
patrimoine sardo pourquoi faire
sangloter les douaniers or ce matin au
stand dassary basé sur quoi tout le
talent bilan légèrement lourdes pratique
j'ai mis des souffleurs de conviennent
mieux que sa chérie mais meurt moi aussi
la grande
à quoi ça tient tout de même les prises
de conscience
c'est en pensant à tes valises que j'ai
compris que tu partes est vraiment bon
tu veux dire voilà tu vois je suis pas
le seul à lever l'embargo
figure toi que moi ça dure et en quoi
diffère le vend des pneus roi débat
woerth soin de soi qu'à un moment la
première de la saison sera du pareil
c'est une du baril plus de 300 que je
l'attends et balle à plat
mais il a choisi son jour pas vraiment
mon trésor décombres pardon jeudi mais
les petits picon les epn attention ça
pique qui pense bien que d'isolement
un geste qui me touche beaucoup mon
oreille d'autant qu'il est rare coupet
une du baril il faut le faire mon deuil
comme du beurre ça scoop
oui mais comme il fallait pas lui pas en
général on les laisse sur le rosier
profitant gérer dans une heure les
photos et dans 30 ans il ya plus de
pétrole pense pas la vie repas paris les
sombres
dimanche on dit je faisais ma chambre tu
crois que c'est pour ça moi j'espère
parce que sinon je lui fais bouffer le
routier qui ne nous envie patronat que
veux tu dire j'étais incrédule comme
nous l'avons été durant ces deux
derniers vols
abbassi pignoufs à ce point-là gérons
rien moi je comprends très bas voilà toi
tu comprends tout tu vois jérôme c'est
ça qui va nous manquer son indulgence en
mieux l'heure est enfin venue nous
mordre les doigts
quand je pense à ce que j'ai pu ona cet
himalaya d'égoïsme emploi de goinfrer
veux te laisses ta soeur d'abord
regarder vers l'avenir
très juste en avant tout ma grande
acapulco le pied-à-terre du bon dieu
comme disait d'indiens 35000 habitants
la perle de la côte mexicaine entre tes
pas légal a pas derrière toi la sierra
madre elle sourd et devant les flots tu
vois ça correspond assez est ce que je
te disais 1
o na je voudrais que tu sa chérie tu es
très content de ce qui m'arrive
tu l'as remarqué ça crève les yeux je
sors que nous allons passer un de
sédiments à butiner ton bonheur la
branche des papillons partir ainsi le
coeur léger consciente de n'avoir jamais
vendu ma famille plus heureuse quand la
quittons tu devrait la mettre dans un
vase ce sens aigu de l'à-propos moi qui
me demandait justement quelles bonnes
actions je pourrais encore accompli vite
un vase pour la du barry
en fait je vous rappelle qu'acapulco
mais qu'une étape
émanation parler un peu de la
vulnérabilité du psychisme mal à quels
rapports votre question je me déguise en
julie je me crachent à la figure je me
traite de poulpe
je me n'aucune l'histoire du mexique je
joue les cocus côte en jeu ma plate et
je m'habille lit je me des gratte un
morveux me puma du baril et moi je me
transforme en papillon qu'elle rapporte
au stade at il à voir avec le bout et de
pièces détachées
je fais ma tête on l'a vu tu veux sauver
n'appuie où nous mais jenson mais le
poids samedi par nice qu'à 3 heures du
matin trois heures et quelques examens
de santé d'un courrier mais trois jours
de battre à moi je dois brevet nous soit
trop comment sont l'amphi sur les
dangers de l'imagination pape et le
gillot ne touche plus à ce qui me reste
de globules rouges
et c'est de comprendre gérome jeu
facebook
de deux choses l'une où nous préparons
avec elle son départ imaginaire et donna
tout rentrera dans l'ordre
ce que piper l'ofs appelle la projection
réalisée ou alors alors ou alors nous
bloquons sa fixation et tu entendras
parler d'acapulco
jusqu'à la fin des jours c'est clair à
ce lumineux en fonction de quoi je
continue à me traîner dans la boue
autant que les tickets mea culpa mais
enfin réfléchi comment aurions-nous
l'air de croire à son départ si nous en
écartant les motivations les motivations
les motivations qu'elle croit fondées
c'est ça qui m'emmerde qu'elle lacroix
fondée
pourquoi parce qu'elles le sont
la question à me regarder comme ça
jamais vu un mammifère supérieurs m'ont
apporté leur outil qui va réduire à la
cuisson au fait tu dois 543 bon mais les
valises à bon compte nous en ferons pas
avais tu permets moi aussi je fais
semblant avec mon frère ne soit pas
radin toute façon ils vous n'en fallait
des notes cet été pour cap martin et si
demain na n'était plus là
- 8 - -12 égal moins huit +12 égale +4
plus quatre nombres négatifs
pas de chance positif braves
or entre le négatif et le positif
le plus petit nombre et le nombre
positif
pas tout à fait négatif tu ainsi moins 3
est plus petit que +44 +4 moins -3 égale
capuçon et gagnent 12 4 et 3 e set
alors pourquoi dis-tu 12 mai parce que 4
x 3 12 exactement la c4 +3 abbaoui vu
sous cet angle
tu n'as pas le choix donc à plus 3 6 7 7
et un nombre négatif presque positif
miracles of
on continue ben vas y c'est un peu mon
sentiment
sans compter que j'ai des scrupules
allons bon dames faire bosser le prof
dimanche c'est anti syndicale rassure
toi est en année leur rendement il
serait étonnant que la chose s'ébruite
il fit à plus de solliciter des
explications pour comme ça une idée qui
a donc cessé de me prendre pour un
demeuré
si je vois bien pour vous une norme être
légale patate quand je dis cela au
besoin de le dire ça spief tu marches au
flair ya pas que les maths dans la vie
en position intéressante même que si je
veux aussi je vous colle chiche
tenez le bowler par exemple un le
bonheur parlez-moi de st alors thomas
boullier on sèche
au contraire je nage pour des questions
précises
après six d'accord le bonheur de martin
c'est important pour vous il n'y a rien
de plus important que le bonheur de ceux
qu'on aime plus que votre bonheur à vous
pareil le voleur de l'un fait le bonheur
de l'eau vouliez le sens venir à 0 gros
comme une citrouille soit points de mon
stylo pourquoi parceque vous dit des
conneries hypothèses martine vous planez
qu'est-ce que son bonheur et vous
plaquer ça fait toujours le vôtre coincé
cette hypothèse le terrain de boue que
si martine ne m'aimait pas question
boullier est ce que ma mère me disait
mais bien sûr qu'elle vous aime aussi ne
parte elle pas hypothèse elle part elle
nous aiment égales par hypothèse pour
son voleur parce que hypothèse
l'amour est une chose est de bonne
humeur en est une autre
kelis c'est pas moi monsieur mon avis tu
t'intéresses bas tant qu'à faire alors
je t'en fais cadeau ta mère ne partira
pas
vous croyez j'en suis certain vous venez
d'être pleinement le fait que les vagues
de ma vie à north bay mais l'enfant mais
comment vous le savez qu'elle ne partira
pas au ce soit à quoi état de choses tu
penses une femme comme l admirable
vachement à venir à ma mère ne le fais
pas dire aussi rien que l'idée qu'elle
pourrait de cause parce qu on est poli
tu as ta mère pour la gare toute seule
dans la nature
mais pourquoi vous dites tout seul
voyage avec ton père est toujours
possible mais dans ce cas de beaucoup
mon père que veux tu dire des
contribuables c'est pas ce qui manque
tu te rends compte ce qui va pouvoir
nous entretenons une porte je n'aime pas
son objectif c'est tout bizarrement si
ma mère pour la guerre dans la nature
pourquoi il sort est elle seule mais
parce que la poule y est vous la
cherchez la colle pourquoi litres et
seul un pas pourquoi ça sur la question
ne se pose pas puisque minutes moi je la
pose mais enfin laurent comment peux tu
imaginer que cette femme qui fut pendant
quinze ans un modèle de comment dire
exemple ou enfin bref que c'est cette
femme ta mère ta mère le rang puis tout
à coup comme ça de but en blanc du jour
lendemain arriver à ce sondage
vous dites je dis arrivé à sous elle est
vieille ma mère non non au contraire
elle est encore très jeune mais les quoi
moi je n'ai renoncé parce que les deux
peut-être oubliez moi je n'ai jamais ici
un vieux biniou dit là mais ben voyons
ça explique sûr qu'elle ne part pas mais
qu'est ce qu'elle irait faire tout seul
dans la nature cette casserole montpetit
silence poulhiès de média trust dans les
yeux aux normands maman tu sais pourquoi
tu ne parles pas parce que ton âge c'est
foutu voilà ce qu'ils pensent ce contre
mais regardez là ma mère jeunes comme ça
on n'en fait plus ses yeux ses jambes
la chasse y avait regroupé des princes
seul douala tueur ça non mais dites vous
traînez à des plis vouloir maintenant
mans va t'en vite les types comme lui ça
finirait par de creuser des rides
je veux pas brûler raison je veux pas je
veux pas je veux pas je vote pas
[Applaudissements]
nan je voudrais organise une citronnade
partie dans le jardin vous n'aimez pas
la sepronat laissez moi vous expliquer
vous préférez de la bière il a insisté
pour je veux dire cette leçon d'algèbre
à moi aussi le sirop de casse mais
c'était qu'un prétexte en vérité j'ai
été votre veste il fait une chaleur
je ne pouvais tout de même pas lui et je
crois certainement pas comment il est
particulièrement mal c'est un grand
garçon de 14 ans de croire que sa mère
en avoir écouté notre la manière dont il
a présenté les choses horriblement
tendant aussi en fait j'ai j'ai manqué
d'arguments mais pas du tout vous avez
au contraire brillamment défendu mon
potentiel de sagesse et de résignation
votre potentiel ce privilège conférée
par la wii
non
comment non j'ai simplement tenté
d'expliquer à laurent et j'entends bien
qu'à mon agent de développement à une
famille
oui ça compte double avez vous déjà
essayé le jus d'ananas ocz au salon ok
j'ai encore dit qu'il vous ne prenez moi
j'ai été pris au dépourvu bon que voulez
vous dire mais devant l'énormité de ce
que pensent et votre fille sort pitié
laissez moi d'union je me sens pas le
courage de supporter le choc est ce
qu'il croit
j'ai un amant mais c'est précisément sa
note ça
l'énormité cet affreux il vous a déclaré
nettement que j'avais de moins que vous
pourriez remarquer ce conditionnel
témoigne au moins d'une certaine
délicate elle et vous avez de ces
indulgences n'en suit pas moins
bouleversé d'autant plus que c'est ma
faute
j'avoue m'être conclua maison le à
entretenir certains enfin certaines
illusions les illusions sont des labels
de jeunesse hélas oui justement à mon
âge on a 12 ans et je vous en prie
thomas garder votre belle franchise est
il imaginable que je puisse avoir un
amant certes non merci mon année mais si
c'est pas une question de
non au contraire épanoui comme vous
l'êtes aller n'ayons pas peur des mots
c'est tout à fait tout à fait oui
désirable mon dieu à à 100% notre pointu
théoriquement à huy ah oui un peu par
chance vous avez d'autres qualités à par
chance le biais des qualités comment
dirais je vois qu'ils font contrepoids
voilà oui par exemple de toutes ces
qualités n'est ce pas qui qui impose le
respect c'est ça que je voulais faire
comprendre à laurent que vous étiez
avant tout une femme respectable
prodigieux pardon cette faculté de
trouver le mot qui personnalisera
celui-ci la première fois que je vous ai
vu je me suis dit martin a bien de la
chance en voilà une qui n'aura pas à
s'en faire pour sa personnalité si elle
ne la trouve pas lui s'en chargera
je reconnais que aussi depuis ce jour là
je change de sujet je crois en effet
gagnerait je dois avouer que je jalouse
mason pourquoi m'avoir fait mais je
regrette a relevé sur la conscience
maintenir 20 à dieu merci je suis une
femme respectable
puis j'ai du temps que vous me
l'apprenez
vous vous moquez noah vient surtout pas
que pourriez-vous espérer d'autre
baissez les yeux que vous ai-je fait
c'est ça votre force vous ne faites rien
vous êtes là c'est tout avec vos yeux
franchement je n'en veux comprendre la
moindre des courtoisies tout de même à
propos pour quelles raisons croyez vous
que je tard vous n'allez pas prétendre
prétend rien je vous pose une question
pourquoi partez-vous subtile ce retour à
l'envoyeur
écoutez notre juil
pitié
fait tête sinon c'est thomas je ne vous
entends pas mais que voulez-vous que je
vous dise rien à écouter j'écoule ya
vraiment des circonstances sur celle ci
je ne vois qu'un seul mot dites moi à
dieu c'est un jeu n'est ce pas là sur
thomas sa création d'une femme respecte
a oublié ce jeu on a mis mais c'est que
je vous en prie si vous avez pouvoir
quelques au respect le place très fort
nous attend pour la citronnade thomas je
parle je parle de demain de ne partez
pas comment voulez-vous surtout elle me
dit moi mais qu'est ce que je vous ai
pardonné moi j'avais cru comprendre que
vous me demandiez oui oui je vous
appelez cela ne rien dire n'en parle
parlons-en note
préciser votre pensée connaissez-vous
baldung grien pardon le peintre je crois
que je vais voir non pas du tout moi
même c'est tout à fait par hasard tu es
à cause du calendrier des postes le mien
cette année représente un baldung grien
c'est écrit sur le tableau venus et
l'amour par balles londres in the hands
en dessous les ptt ont toujours fait
beaucoup pour la en l'occurrence il
s'agit d'une vénus très que comment
dirais-je particulièrement un chat d'oc
ah oui et pour cent en fait de deux
visages pour le reste elle est toute nue
alors forcément on ne peut comparer cas
par imagination
maintenant on fait je veux dire en
l'imaginant avec une robe attention de
quoi c'est pas la fermeture éclair
l'affairé celle de la robe que vous êtes
en train de passer à vénus
note 6 bangrin vous avez connu c'est
vous qui seriez aujourd'hui sur le
calendrier le post est brusquement le
dimanche 17 mai au milieu de l'après
midi
le vésuve entre en éruption alors n'en
croyez rien à te dès la première minute
je vous ai vu ça ce n'est pas vrai
laissez-moi vous mentir match et j'ai
tellement d'avoir été aveugle j'espère
que ma respectabilité n'a rien à
craindre de votre subi de guérison
contraire d'être quoi de plus
respectable que c'est que votre que que
la vénus valent donc green charnellement
respectable surtout de nos jours où la
sexualité triomphe on peut en faire
emboucher les trompettes d'une victoire
libératrice
dieu merci le le respect ne connaît plus
de frontières la lafam cet égard est
devenue respectable dans sa totalité
tentative de l'homme pour parfaire cette
on s'amuse
cette unification le petit considéré
comme louis l'expression de ces hommages
les plus respectueux on vous rassure
je ne suis pas certain de vouloir vous
rassurer ni que vos lunettes sont
efficaces contre les ultraviolets vaut
quoi
c'est une image attendez-vous dans les
minutes qui suivent déferlement tonnage
savons depuis quelques instants les mots
ne sont plus que de lamentables bidule
ce qui m'arrive est tellement tellement
aimé ça vous donne tellement tout celui
qui fait l'ignorent nat
je suis un ovni sortie du tunnel mais
qu'il traverse un ciel inconnu coûte à
la fois soumis aux lois de la pesanteur
de la version c'est dégueulasse alors
nous nous avions prévu un effet comique
si je demande la parole refuse et je
voudrais sacré profs n'ont pas du tout
même lorie sébastien bombal à l'autre je
déclare solennellement que nate n'est en
rien responsable est inutile profs nous
avons très bien vu qu'il s'agissait d'un
viol
c'est là je mesure le nez dans le
vinaigre il se marre c'est toi la dacie
trois là ne pourrait pas pour et
grandiose que la vie est complexe
mardi la tonne
comment at il dit ça déjà à une
incoercible attirance
l'un colère si l'attirance décidément
toi dans le style qui tentera sûrement
une vocation rentré j'étais fait pour
les noces et banquets
est-ce que tu emploies comme crème
pardon pour le visage pas pourquoi tu
trouves que c'est par contraire c'est
fantastique
tu as eu la peau de jeune fille mais je
vais te faire une confidence
c'est ma peau de jeune fille
juste très peu c'est venu comment les
léchouilles du futur beau-frère sur tes
mains oh je suis dit c'est intéressant
sur le plan anthropologique fait partie
de quoi du calendrier des postes
coutts et lumineuse et allume tous le
même talent de ce coup mn baldung grien
tu connais le peintre non chérie c'est
toute une éducation à faire ne leur ont
jamais et ben voilà
changeons de sujet nous ça a été une
brosse à dents souvient j'ai mes
archives
maintenant ce que tu fabriques est au
cinéma avec une brosse à dents ça venait
de l'acheter
oui et méfiante qui en compta les poils
le film et terrasson margaine babre
attendra or un chef-d'oeuvre elle nous
n'étions pas prêts destinés à ça si tu
n'avais pas laisser tomber tu as bros
wii est obligé si ça faisait dix minutes
que tu de tortue yoman asticots fallait
en finir j'ai plongé
seulement dans le noyau de ses mystères
pas plus grosse que de pâquerettes
le destin sans doute l'avait englouti
alors pour ne pas me relever bordeaux où
j'ai ramassé ta main marc toi il aura
fallu quinze ans pour enrayer
on leur donnera sûrement un jour coadout
marienbad
j'y retournerais pour voir la fin ça
manque
ça ne m'a jamais manqué
merci
je voudrais te dire quelque chose bien
dit si seulement je savais quoi je te
fais confiance d'ici là dit tu trouveras
non en fait je n'ai rien bravo ça
simplifie sa peau est si nous étions des
êtres supérieurs des cartes par exemple
l'éloquence silence des carpes
mais ça suffirait pas à ma foi si tu
tiens on peut s'en tenir là non je sens
que tu serais déçu au fond nous vivons
méchamment notre époque toi et moi
parfaitement dans le vent c'est à dire
en plein problèmes du couple
ah non nous ne la tue patauge
il s'agit de moi de moi toute seule
voiture pour y sortir moi tout seul ça
veut dire moi de la tête aux pieds sans
rien autour ni personne solutionnant à
ma manière un problème dont j'ai
l'exclusivité
mon problème c'est comme ça et surtout
dors tranquille en ce qui concerne le
couple tout ce que tu devais faire tu la
fais tu as accompli son devoir avec une
conscience de maître maçon
s'il existe un chef-d'oeuvre en la
matière tu peux te flatter de l'avoir
parfaitement réussi un couple sans
faille un et indivisible comme la
république alors d'où vient l'erreur de
la base cherry une erreur de calcul
tu n'as pas su compter jusqu'à 2
je comprends pourquoi tu inspires les
profs de maths entre autres comment
s'appelle-t-il en trop qu'est ce qu'il
fait dans la vie quand il ne téléphone
pas il est capitaine au long cours
stewart voilà tu connais ça a commencé
comme un indic lui par une incoercible
attirance comment on dit bourdieu petit
grand gros maigres chevelu chauvin dieu
on va lâcher autre chose ça d'état qui
lui donne consistance que j'ai pas cette
impression pénible d'être échangé contre
un ectoplasme chausse du 43
bah voilà une bonne pointure ça comme
moi c'est du 42 je sais maintenant tu ne
pourras pas me voler mes pompes
que se passe-t-il chéri aux questions
purement formel je suppose c'est l'air
tellement moins content que ce matin
content content peut pas rester figé
dans le contentement comme une souche on
est content mais on bouge on évolue en
cause on essaie de comprendre toute
façon compte ou non sur toi je n'ai
aucunement l'intention d'aller bombarder
acapulco
tu trouves un repère intacte dans tout
son insalubrité avec ces moustiques et
sans qu'un à oui parce que là bas ça
pullule lundi le canton mais quand on
attrape à la malaria h l'acompte je vais
bouffer une cuisse humaine
non ne me répond pas
dix mois au moins ce qu'il a de mieux
que
non mais ça ne me dit pas oui j'ai une
surprise pour toi tu fermes les yeux
ouvrez plutôt teaser il va faire tes
bagages nous partons demain pour
acapulco
quel jeu de mah qu'est ce qui est
dommage que tu sois fort clos en quoi
est ce que tu as fait privé du bénéfice
d'un droit que tu n'as pas exercer dans
les délais prévus
bref le parquet mais jerry dans le
mariage on a toute la vie pour exercer
ses droits mais toute la vie n'est pas
un mariage
qu'est ce que tu veux dire dans la vie
on accorde aux autres que le temps de sa
passion mais envoie l'arbitré de moi je
vais rester à accepter ce petit à moi
démocrate et syndiqués des mecs louis à
les bagages est toute petite j'adorais
le kidnapping du siècle
parce que tu crois que je représente un
plaisante pas tu dis n'importe quoi
c'est encore plus gros parce que je peux
dire sinon n'importe quoi
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire un clément la
solution ce serait dans l'inventer mais
je ne sais pas j'ai des ambitions ou
dessus de mes moyens
alors qu'est ce qui me reste est
suite
désolé désolé on ne peut pas savoir à
quel point à c'était si charmant nous
deux là bas où ça mais un cap ou le
court mais si tu attaques ne suffit pas
je peux t'offrir un blanc moi tu ne
trouves au lasso pas je manquais
d'oxygène on dit moi même qui vient de
mettre cette idée en tête
quelle idée mais que nous pourrions
partir ensemble alors tu acceptes je le
regrette
autant que toi rien ne compensera là je
vois qu'aujourd'hui la nous atteignons
des 100 m
c'est par hasard de ma sincérité
quelque chose m'échappe mais jérôme
n'est pas parce que je pars que tu ne
compte plus
je n'abandonne pas d'un coup d'aile
quinze ans de ma vie c'est un passé
auquel je tiens
s'il en était autrement ce serait
épouvantable
j'aurais ni plus ni moins l'impression
de te tromper ah bon parce que comme ça
tu ne l'as pas en gironde formalise pas
au contraire dans ma candeur j'avais
tendance à me sentir un peu chaud pour
qui fraude suscite doigts pour qu'ils me
prends tu ta pointure 43
c'est un abstinent tibétains mélange
tout le passé le présent l'avenir
serrions les chapitres au chapitre de
mon avenir
tu n'y es pas
c'est du reste ça mon regret ma
désolation
mais tu n'y es pas comment pourrais-je
me tromper
quoi rien ne vaut une bonne explication
à chaud tout à coup d'un optimisme à
l'ena qui a commencé tout petit rien
chercher sa brosse à dents je t'emmène
au cinéma et nous laisserons nos 15 ans
de plus investir et qu'est ce que tu
racontes nous sommes encore très jeune
encore mais pas très juste de quoi
risquer une dernière me oui c'est ça est
ce qu'on la sait ce que je vais faire je
vous remets pas sur la même couleur
vraiment
attend peut-être celui-là nat je t'aime
moi aussi
alors ça ne change rien ça ce n'est pas
nouveau mais qu'est ce que tu veux que
je leur dois tenter quelque chose
oui bon alors si je comprends bien je
crois que je dise quoi que je fasse se
dit ou fait ne cherche plus est deux
mois seulement à partir avec ma
bénédiction
oui eh ben c'est ça je vais inventer ça
je mérite ce que tu sais
acapulco n'est pas seulement un porc du
mexique
c'est mon acte de courage je n'aurais
pas deux fois ce courage là c'est pour
ça que je me cramponne moi vous écoute
bon voyage est à marquer d'une pierre
blanche
qu'est ce que tu veux dire
c'est la première fois que tu penses que
moi
oui faisons l'amour bureau à la santé de
la pointure 43
parce que tu as beau dire dans une
situation pareille
il faut tout de même qu'il y ait la cocu
moi ça je n'ai agi que par politesse la
neige est lentement j'avais café chaud
mais pas comment il me manque ma femme
artiste mentir je trouverai des choses
qui fâchent plus vrai des choses comme
celles que tu as trouvé pour ma soeur
oui en un sens c'est aussi dégoûtant
dans l'eau il ya depuis mention nantes
il ne le dit surtout pas jusqu'où tu
comptes et à l'est par polymérase une
citronnade n'avait pas souffert d'une
t'imagines tout de même paul je
m'imagine rien menteur je t'écoute
tu lui embrasser les mains beau et après
c'est la question que je te pose
elles meurent et giflé quand je ne sais
pas au juste mais je m'attendais à
recevoir une gifle de momar lo story
par politesse de toute façon je méritais
une gifle à croire que non chrétiennes
la partie fils il fallait le temps du
réflexe je n'en avais peut-être au merci
pour notre opinion que tu avais
l'opinion n'a aucune influence sur les
pulsions libido motrices de nappes
question si elle n'avait pas giflé
j'aurais rompu le contact
à quel moment avant ou après mais
n'évitent paraître mais avant bien sûr a
alors ça comme politesse et martin la
maîtrise que deux camps même état danger
permanent pour l' équilibre psychique
des faveurs sont les polypes tous genres
pour les névroses et martin un proche
parent
je ne tiens pas à contenter d'un au rexy
mental dit moin en moin mi moigne plus
maintenant parfait si tu juges ne juge
plus la cause est entendue elle même
mais non à ce soir et n'oublie pas que
c'est un dîner de gala tenue de soirée
de rigueur
si tu n'as pas d'autre cache misère que
tout venant pas la peine de revenir j'ai
un smoking ouvre le moteur seulement
j'ai pas de noeud papillon parfait tu
resteras de dos ce sera toujours ça de
gagné non non comment nos salons je
refuse en val d'auge malentendu je sais
pas comment tu sais pas mais je suis
parti aux veilles et le bout de mes
beauty l'est dans mes oreilles
allez laurent bon mouvement c'est là que
tu as mal non six comme la trois
semaines pour couper attaque on peut
marquer trois semaines c'était vrai et
dédé est mon oeil
ma demande docteur ben justement tu as
lagarde est la garantie d 2 85e
mes cheveux par mieux que ce que ça te
coup tu te mets ont lu ta mère de
bissone t'attendent de bissone le prof
ravale son agent et moi je tends france
emballe l'héritier dans du coton et du
japon un petit mal au ventre
si pas mal au ventre mais si je te
faisais une grosse tête n'est pas géré
la tête mais pour d'autres écrivains
laurent ta mère fait semblant de partir
martinez moindre son semblant de la
croire le prof fait semblant de lui une
cheville et les mains tout le monde fait
semblant de quelque chose que toi qui
m'a semblé n'a rien dit pourquoi me tue
façon anormale au ventre pour que ta
mère fasse semblant de rester 150 balles
non 200 non plus un paquet de cigarettes
non sans compter que le toubib a dit que
si nous leur en ai vraiment pour miami
alors tu parles d'une histoire n'y a que
les crétins qui ne se font pas opéré de
l'appendicite
je suis à crétins tu n'as s'est dit pour
que je le sache écoute moi mon chéri si
on tempère de l'appendicite jeu
toutefois un vélomoteur
je supporte pas le cas alors tu préfères
que ta mère sunrise fais toi c'est tout
ce que tu as trouvé pour que le reste tu
as mieux à me proposer un oui j'ai mieux
ça va loin ce que tu viens là
faut laisser moment choisi c'est ça
qu'il faut faire pas vous laisser
choisir parce qu'on préfère nous ce
qu'elle pourra faire l
pour une fois avec toi j'ai mes choix je
décide de tout comme si on n'existait
pas je sais juste que tu dis ça aussi
qui l'a décidé puis tu sais reprochés
remontent partir ta bonne mine
depuis le temps que toi nous a quittés
mais qu'est ce que tu racontes t'ai
jamais là le jour on ne voit pas mais le
soir c'est toi qui ne voit pas quand on
parle n'est plus personne mais quand tu
parles on croirait entendre un despote à
la télé oui c'est vrai j'ai souvent à
l'esprit absorbés par des tas de choses
c'est dommage qu'on soit pas des choses
je gagne votre vie tu payes des sous ça
vous fait vivre non si on n'a pas faim a
dit dans sa grande histoire
je mange ta soupe aux tuyaux ce qui
m'empêche de faire sauter les dans ta
bonne foi papa ouais t'as ptet 13 ans si
ces plaisirs grenoble où tu peux te
pousse pas du col si ça se trouve qu'en
gens réfléchissent te faire avaler tes
conneries avec un entonnoir
oh je regrette qu est ce que tu
regrettes papa et ben vas-y le canton
soit un grand matelas mais bon voilà
c'est ça c'est tout ce que je sais moi
parce que tu veux faire plus tard
si un jour tu reviens on en parlera
tu crois qu'elle va partir franchement
je sais pas mais laissera choisir soit
là c'est tout si tu es là mais alors là
vraiment la même si elle part sur
qu'elle revient bah ça tu peux pas te
dire mais elle revient assure même que
je resterais avec toi le temps qu'il
faudra tiens je me marierai pas
jusqu'à ce qu'il revienne parole d'homme
[Applaudissements]
ça s'arrange où je parle de la table oh
oui la table de ça s'arrange doit en
somme nous a battus voire chaudhry
maintenant j'en parle d'eux qu'est ce
que tu en penses dans son traité sur la
mécanique du complexe la gears of estime
t on quelqu'un latéraux la raison jérôme
ça porte bonheur
elle part je ne sais pas moi je sais
alors pourquoi n'admettez mon petit que
tu me dises non non ils sont tous à brad
et dans un parapluie était psychologue
non cela mieux peut-être
bon très bien d'accord qu'elle choisisse
veut user de ses droits de citoyen
premières parfois qu'elle en douze mois
je n'en ai pas pu aller plus loin ce
choix
ces droits que lui offrent ses monstres
c'est de bien réfléchir parce que si
elle choisit de partir je viens où les
portes je pousse la cheminée je mûris
frais n'oublie pas les trous de serrure
quand je pense qu'on est là un bon dieu
ce petit roman de hall de gare
alors que l'humanité entière est aux
prises avec angoissant problème de sa
survivance et le plus fort c'est que
l'humanité sur lui parce que je te dise
problème là on arrive à résoudre tous
les problèmes trouvent leurs solutions
tous sauf un seul est la femme je tombe
dessus et ça c'est stop chandelles
organisée par la famille pour souhaiter
bon vent à madame c'est pas beau ça
t'as déjà vu plus noble plus généreux
plus qu'en calme toi jérôme tu vas te
couper l'appétit
faire
et
j'ai créé les porter à cause de trouver
un noeud papillon à dimanche soir c'est
pas tellement sa gauche et finit par un
délicieux toutes les tailles et dans le
bac pour pantalon et veste de smoking à
peu toute une histoire j'ai hérité ou
vidada grand-oncle vieux vous êtes plus
grand que lui ce thème ça me fait penser
qu'il faut que j'aille rallonger la
béchamel
et l'ambiance à dont la table sa fugue
et j'écoutais mon vieux autant vous
prévenir tout de suite après le fromage
j'ai l'intention de me pendre non je ne
dis pas ça pour vous est désagréable
simplement si vous trouvez ça gay
amusez-vous maintenant excusez moi j'ai
pas très bien saisi que la tension avez
vous de me pendre après le fromage
vous voulez dire se passera dans le
grenier et je compte sur vous sur moi
oui pour me faire la courte échelle
infléchir au mur je sais je pourrais me
servir d'un tabouret mais j'ai besoin de
chaleur humain est l'outil juan ne sera
pas la première fois que vous aiderez un
qu'entre à résoudre son problème
alors ça comme celui sur mes gardes et
le tonus 3 fia les allées à la coop
cassé ou la poutre voyons il en fait
aussi peur etc ou d'usure à l'une trois
petits coups de scie alors vous voulez
dire
figurez vous que j'ai la faiblesse
d'imaginer qu'en cette occasion ma femme
pour être ajourné son départ ainsi pour
ce mec est ce que vous croyez que j'ai
réussi cependant plafond pour faire
l'économie d'un lustre
si je comprends bien c'est une forme de
chantage d'hier est un imbécile
franchement je ne pense pas je ne
pensais pas alors cessé de me regarder
comme si vous pensiez mon avis reprend
longer coop avec les moyens du bord et
voyez vous un inconvénient
ce profond silence toujours chéri quand
un ange passe
apparemment on ne sort pas seulement
l'argenterie ce soir incoercible
attirante placier ne vous plaignez pas
les classes et chérie on les cite
n'est ce pas prof exacte des citations
son excellent palliatif au manque
d'idées personnelles
attendez qu'on succès auprès de la dame
à votre place je
j'essaierai de lui tailler le compliment
qu'elle attend relever le défi thomas et
votre robe est très comment dire trahi
et tacheté my va sauter dessus mais nous
sommes vraiment tous chercher rives à
moi le service moi je n'aime pas ça
prendre son seul mérite que tu sois
dedans se servent de toit pour se mettre
en valeur et elle y arrive mais en
bouffant un peu ton naturel et pourtant
tu es très belle ce soir parce qu'autant
que les autres soirs en dépit des
circonstances presque aussi belle que le
soir où tu m'attendais au bord de la
route
sous la pluie dans ton ciré et rouge un
petit poulain ruisselant sur la tête
transis de froid et d'inquiétude à cause
d'une panne de carburateur qui m'avait
valu d'être en retard d'une heure parce
qu'aussi belle aussi que le soir de
notre douzième anniversaire de mariage
du mathan des assises dans un fauteuil
la table mise comme ce soir avec dans
mon assiette cette note
moi j'avais oublié je rentré les mains
vides alors qu'il m'a dit c'est 3 que
j'attendais et rien d'autre parce que si
belle aussi que le soir où dumas
accueilli sur le seuil de la porte du
jardin impatiente de m'annoncer que tu
étais enceinte
bell ce soir presque autant que chaque
soir que dieu fait depuis 15 ans où tu
m'as temps chez nous et où je t'apporte
en échange marque de rentrée merci merci
d'être presque aussi mal ce jeudi
presque
c'est à dire juste assez pour être un
bon souvenir de demain sans sans effacer
mes souvenirs d'hier
madame est servie
[Applaudissements]
aaaaaah satisfaire aux revendications
des viticulteurs chérien vrai beurre ton
petit comment tu fais tu pour faire du
beurre avec deux essais échanges à côté
la culotte de velours du bon dieu les
gabelous chin de la moutarde avec une
sauce pareil tu as vu ça
alors pourquoi la tunisie sera table
roulante rajuste motards mon quartier
or dijon est une ville a dit excusez moi
alors au contraire chéri le rire est au
menu souvient du soin ou et qu'est ce
qui me fait penser à sa famille leurs
tiges avec un roi qui ce soir là nous
avons passé un de ces quarts des cas pas
de quoi m'adresse par les passeurs les
robes lincourt à nos amis rôle incombait
à théza virent aux blacks ou non le soin
puis son petit nez tu te souviens un
quart d'heure d'oublier je vois pas ce
que les roubles 1 co 11 avoir une
baguette de pain à aa
tout compte fait les bons quarts d'heure
ne nous ont pas manqué certains duré 20
minutes d'autres seulement au disque
mais là dans le rendre à dix et vingt
trente visés par deux essais par les
mots comme à toulon bon quart d'heure y
compris celui-ci
ce dernier quart de tour point
remarquable et durant lequel tout ce
jour ah bon est ce que tu veux dire
l'état phone lindingre oblet cours de
souvient germany pour les intimes
théron de jambes devant ces 10 kg de
poids trio aux meurons johnathan nous et
les genoux mais je rougis sa semblable
et votre femme et son chignon la tour de
pise en bringuebal à chaque fois qu'elle
tournait la tête top à bord tribord
mais selon maxime vrai bon quart d'heure
quand tu m'a demandé de me coiffer comme
je t'assure chérie ça te donnera du
caractère on me jeu du ca en point j'ai
remarqué quand les attentions sont
blessés par les mamère ne suis pas
contre les bonnes intentions elles ont
pavé quinze ans de ma vie et ça n'a pas
été l'enfer aux razzias non non ça a été
15 fois 365 jours viable et enviable
pour point que beaucoup seraient en
droit de me demander de quoi je me plais
aussi ne me plains pas ah non non je me
penche sur mon cas
un camping à turin je me fous les
records seulement c'est le mien comme
dit l'autre on respire avec le nez qu'on
a
je dois vous paraître de nego is n'est
pas du tout maintenant comment pas du
tout géré au mieux non en aucune manière
d'omar voyons naître vous aiguille j'ai
fait mes preuves non deux jours entiers
d'égoïsme son enfant et parent devant
témoins j'exige l'abrogation de cette
performance ou alors qu'on me dise ce
qui montre un dynamisme qu'on craint une
rechute on aurait tort l'altruisme
monsieur comme la rougeole
une fois guéri on est immunisé pour le
restant de ses jours goodman ans par le
talent est là que de choses à dire en
vrac qu'elle stocke qui va falloir
bradés prends ton temps chéri et même un
peu du sien qui permet tout ce qui
m'appartient est à toi oui aux un peu
tes meubles sont les miens tout salaire
c'est mon budget
ton fils est à moi sa propre personne
est devenu mon mari tu as mis des idées
dans ma tête tant les opinions
politiques color mon bulletin de vote
des joies sont les miennes tes soucis
des silences des projets des habits
c'est parfaitement vrai tous ceux qui
t'appartient est à moi est le temps que
je possède quelque chose qui
n'appartiennent pas au même âge on est
affamé mais quand même les nachi je sais
qu'il écrit des poèmes
tu seras mon fils dis à ton père que tu
écrit des poèmes trésor la base est dit
le papa j'écris des poèmes
tu vois ton fils et 1 contre en maths
mais le mien écrit des poèmes continue
mon trésor ça ne sert à rien les maths
c'est moi laissez parler votre future
belle-soeur les maths ça me sert à rien
qu'à faire de faux calculs tous les
calculs sont faux il n'ya de juste le
bonheur on se donne et ça ça ne se
calcule pas ça prend ça se cueille se
respire soit un cancre où nos rêves
imagine voit les choses à ta convenance
invite appartient et une en recul récent
et poèmes maman laisse parle est amer
quant à ton fils si tu veux en faire un
polytechnicien aaa
sourire les ptt savent ce qu'ils font
qui ont lu sur le calendrier
la vénus de balle de grippe plutôt qu'un
problème de robinets du reste ne vous y
trompez pas celle là non plus n'aime pas
les maths puisque tu es un connard six
mois chez je viens en une seule phrase
de t'éviter 15 ans d'amphi magistral sur
pythagore ses pompes et ses oeuvres
c'est ce qui me ferait plaisir de mon
fromage non un peu de musique
oui parce qu'après le fromage se
passe-t-il thomas vous n'aimez pas la
musique
si c'est le fromage il impressionne
oh merci mon ange
souper aux chandelles et musique douce
au mecheri nous vivons une super
production du temps d'hollywood un
instant car et grands sont invités à
danser
tu danses ciel le roi de la publicité
pauvre cargo
bonjour bon danseur nancy si tôt n'a
rien perdu depuis le réveillon de 1963
moi aussi j'ai des enjeux chérigié
assoit son assiette quoi penses tu et à
toi
pense à ce que sera demain pour toi sans
moi non ce que pourrait être demain pour
nous deux ça c'est facile à imaginer tu
as 15 ans de référence non changer quoi
tout a commencé par mois par toi comme
d'habitude
les yeux ouverts ça change un homme
l'add on sait ça oui je t'ai mis au
monde je me mettais droit à toulouse i
pour voir je suis à la jambe et je
trouve plutôt bonne vie matt laisse-moi
réparer les erreurs sont humaines jamais
compris en quoi cette locution india
pouvait servir d'excusé cherchait pas
d'excusés tu fais bien
je demande seulement comme une chance
vous fait achevé de coupe que les deux
deux livres variés que disions nous ah
oui mais je faisais de mon temps de
parole vous savez j'ai n'y aurait que
c'était à ce point agréable à temps de
parole aussi sont confortables libre
détendue on se laisse aller au fil du
mot mon âge leur temps entre deux
phrases c'est y voit une phrase achevé
un vrai luxe ne me voyais pas jouer ici
mais je n'avais pas l'intention je
compte même en abuser oh vous connaissez
l'histoire des deux presses on roule qui
tourne en rond dans un bocal depuis 15
ans un jour l'un d'eux se tourner vers
notre évidement vous qu'est-ce qu'on
fait mercredi
[Rires]
[Musique]
comme il est dit dans le livre de
jérémie en raison des circonstances
les réjouissances n'auront pas vu si
nous décidions le contraire
1 allez on innove en raison des
réjouissances les circonstances n'auront
pas lieu
chance c'est bien ce que tu m'as demandé
au delà
croyez vous croyez vous qu'une
capitulation plus être une victoire mais
bien longtemps de chéri le plus belle
victoire qui fait le gros dos havrais
merci mon nom je considérais mecheri que
je ne capitule pas
la chance que je te donne géraud tu me
donnes
vous avez entendu il me parle ça veut
dire que oui forcément pour me donner ma
il faut que tu restes
[Applaudissements]
fillon de la raison à tous non je tiens
à te déclarer solennellement demandé que
désormais parce que tu comprends plus
rien n'existe mais nous arrête parce que
nous ne comptent plus nous n'y a plus il
n'y a plus que toi et si nous nous
mettions from a une gueule à l'aéroport
est il existe au moins cheriaa tu peux
nous dire maintenant il existe toute
façon il existe ou non pas il est mort
acapulco est toujours sur la wii mais un
quart bon gras toi oh bon sang ça
soulage et pourtant tu vois quelque
chose me dit j'ai toujours gardé
confiance en évidence lors des
apparences notez bien que j'aimerais
cela bien fait qu'une question de
logique que pour donner une chance à ces
gros problème je maintiens mes cheveux
n'empêche bien wellington ah non pas de
quart d'heure mais la preuve est faite
alors d'en parler je voudrais tout de
même vous dire tu mets mon bureau pu
constater que je m'excuse allons
rétablir les postes arrières vous en
tombent je voudrais tout de même vous
avez tout à fait raison gros boulot je
voudrais tout l'amdi et annonçant qu'il
faut apprendre aux enfants à garder la
tête froide
pourquoi en france ils deviennent des
adultes studio je voudrais tout de même
vous dit peut-être un moment donné vous
dis-je
c'est repos toi mais si maman mais maman
quoi il reste alors maintenant tu le
sais calme-toi à propos de tête froide
va falloir que je mette la mi chemin au
réfrigérateur parce que gl ces contrats
a discuté on n'en parle pas de maj eric
d'une inspection et moelleux six heures
de cours dont 2 or 4e et les plages de
pauline apprendre et vous du fram à un
contre intéressant à lancer la promotion
d'un rasoir saponaire l'est et c'est une
espèce de demeurer à moitié surprendre
et du fromage à mot n'est pas fort
tandis que les japonais les deux heures
de ma 4e ou verrai ce qu'il en reste
on remarque que mon fils ait droit mais
j'aime ce club j'ai des idées qu'ils
opposent les idées se fait toujours peur
à ceux qui ne l'ont pas fait pas alors
collé un slogan alors couper le souffle
est très simple j'entre dans la classe
je les ignore quand même avec
l'inspectrice je passe tout mon temps
passe vite
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas de
megève en ce moment ils entendaient
comprennent très bien le français et le
contraire de mes joueurs qu'ils
comprenaient rien n'est que logique
qu'on respecte rice autres dans la
classe rêver ça mais non mais côtoie
martin à psychologies si en plus en plus
je vais faire de la psycho à mérida
menti doit en faire la psychologie de
même quelle femme admirable
peut-être que j'aille les dégâts non non
non non non non non elle serait un ted
[Applaudissements]
la chanson française ça quand on fait la
paix tu y as pas l'imbécile tous les
appétits le bungalow des rois et laurent
roger holeindre +10 le placer comme ici
et là que 4 à peine d'être leur ôter ce
qui t'arrive vous ment qui le dessert
sans el oued dans sa chambre dans sa
chambre mais je serai dans sa chambre
facebook lui ses valises
[Applaudissements]
la pièce que nous venons de jouer pour
vous ce soir et de yves jamia
le décor est de patcher
les costumes de michel goma
la mise en scène de igas
avec marie fager
henri courseaux
mal mais gomez
illico
et notre micheline boudet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]